hi my name is I'm the director of the
Simons Institute for theory of computing
and last month a group of researchers
gathered at the Simon's Institute for a
workshop of a week-long workshop on a
topic called multi-group fairness and
the validity of statistical judgment
the workshop organizer is Omar rheingold
who's here with us and as my guest today
and omel is the regime matlani professor
of computer science at Stanford
University and he's the director of the
science collaboration with the theory of
algorithmic fairness so Omar thank you
very much for joining us
for an episode of polynox
um do you want to say a word to
introduce yourself before we launch in
um I mean
a territian I've been for
my entire career and so I come from the
theory of computer science of course the
salmon Institute is
currently a focal point of exactly this
kind of area
and I've been working on various areas
cryptography complexity Theory but a lot
of my research especially in the last
decade are on the societal impact of
computation and I guess that's what
we're here to talk about
yeah so in fact within the societal
impact of computation
uh today and we're talking about
algorithmic fairness the topic of this
Workshop
and I know that you certainly have been
studying algorithmic fairness for quite
a while it's not a recent occupation but
probably about a decade and uh I think
um it's fair to say that you and your
colleagues have spearheaded the
foundations of the field
can you start by explaining to us all
what is algorithmic fairness and how it
originated as a field and then we could
segue into the topic of the workshop
which was multi-group fairness and how
that fits in
sure so yeah we started to look at it in
2010 which is a while ago and I think my
collaborators had the vision that uh
computations are going to be more and
more Central in
in making decisions or informing
decisions about individuals and once
algorithms are doing them
and then we should be concerned that
algorithms treat individuals fairly and
just like when other when humans make
decisions we want to make sure that
humans are not discriminating for
example on the basis of various societal
groups like and attributes like race
gender ethnicity and others
um
this was 20 to 10 I think it required
the vision which my collaborators
provided but I think today it's
absolutely clear that we see algorithms
everywhere we see it in the data that we
read the news articles that we read and
and medical decisions about us
and it takes part in the legal system
medical system any kind of
a thing that affects our life
involves algorithms and now we really
want to ask and make sure that these
algorithms are not discriminating
against individuals so that's kind of
the major question of say algorithmic
fairness today
and uh how does multi-group fairness fit
into this larger field
so multi-group fairness is kind of a new
approach something for the last
five six years that tries to address uh
what discrimination could be or what
fairness could mean in a more subtle way
than was discussed before
and the first thing you can start when
you're trying to understand what and
what kind of discrimination is there are
these Notions of group fairness you look
at the entire group perhaps defined by
one of these protected attributes and
you say our people from one group and
are tweeted compared to another group on
average so these are kind of you know on
average whoops for example we can ask
how many individuals from one group
are shown
advertisements about
tech jobs and how many individuals from
the other group
they are shown these ads how many
individuals from one group are accepted
to the university and how many from the
other group what's the fraction and
there are various kind of Notions like
that
what we kind of understood a while ago
and this was actually the motivation of
this and
work from 2010
is that these Notions are very very weak
and it's very easy to
um satisfy these definitions on average
while it is still discriminating against
particular individuals from this
community
multi-crew fairness says that it's not
enough to look at individuals as part of
one group
and we are part of many many groups and
perhaps many Southern groups
intersection of groups of care of what
is our gender and race and other and
even more subtle definitions way of
viewing us and we want it to be the case
that we are treated well
and
regardless of which group we come from
and even when we look at the very very
complex set of subgroups that one could
care about
and and somehow we've been seeing that
this does give a much better protection
against discrimination
a much more subtle protection
so um
[Music]
this gives us
uh guarantees on the average and then
you elaborated that multi-group fairness
is stronger because it will give us a
guarantee on the average but based on my
on our membership in many groups so not
just gender but say gender and race and
age uh etc etc but it's still a notion
that talks about a guarantee for the
average
person with multiple attributes
um
so the Intriguing question that comes up
a perhaps some more technical question
is what does this average uh say about
individuals
right that's that's a wonderful question
our first work
really looked at what we called at the
time individual fairness
and in some sense you can look at
multi-group fairness as a kind of an
interesting point between group fairness
and individual fairness and the more and
more groups you consider the closer you
get into an idea of individual fairness
individual fairness is very appealing I
still like it and I think it's
applicable in many cases
but the issue is that it is hard to get
real data about individuals and on the
other hand we can get
data on groups the thing is that we want
to get data on many many examples so
I'll give you perhaps an example here
you go to a physician and they tell you
um that your probability of some medical
condition in the next 10 years is four
percent
question what does it mean I mean they
don't know everything about you they
essentially fit your a few attributes
about you into a formula and this
formula tells them that people with
these few attributes on average have
this probability is four percent for
this medical condition
what does it tell you what does it tell
about you
perhaps from people from your a group
and this is there is something better to
be said or more accurate and and
in fact there are many studies right and
each study could look at some other
support
and in this group perhaps they'll tell
you you have three percent and in this
group you have two percent the
multi-group fairness wants something
that would make sense
and and will take into account all the
kind of information that could be
gathered
from statistical evidence and rather
than taking into account perhaps a
single study or more
um so going uh so we're going to be
continuously doing this interview uh
Segway into more Technical and more
societal issues
um so now going from the technical to
more General
um
traditionally I guess historically when
people hear the word fairness people are
not technical necessarily who haven't
followed the literature they immediately
think about marginalized unrepresented
groups and so forth I understand that
one of the
um uh appealing aspects of multicore
fairness is that rather than stick to
something that you have in mind in a
priori or something that's mandated by
the law it it has a more General uh it's
a more general definition that can
capture a lot more than people that
today we think are under represented or
marginalized can you expand on that
yeah that's a great point and there are
various reasons for which group furnace
is problematic one reason is perhaps the
one I entered before is that even if we
know what the group is
we can still
discriminate against the group while
being okay on average but the point that
you're raising is that we actually don't
necessarily know how to define the
groups we want to protect and it's it's
known that even members of groups that
are discriminated against our oppressed
don't always know that and that to say
that they are being discriminated
against and that they are a group that
should be viewed in real time and
differently Society who is doing the
Discrimination doesn't always say in
real time realizes that furthermore even
if we know which group specific group
there are many many ways of defining
membership in this group
so we'll take an example that closer to
me which is Judaism
uh defining the group of people that are
Jewish is such a problematic question
and there's been a huge political issue
in Israel for its entire existence and
there has questions of defining it based
on self-identification based on
ethnicity based on religion and so on
and so forth and so even if we know a
kind of a name for the group there may
there could be many many ways of
defining the group and we want perhaps
to simultaneously protect against all of
this group at once and all of these
different ways of defining these groups
at once
and in fact what we can actually see is
that it's important to protect not only
groups that are in general and if need
need protections but subgroups that are
important for a particular task
so one of the examples we gave a while
ago is that of a
an Advertiser for a burger joint and it
wants to discriminate against members of
some subpopulation and to do that they
can advertise and to the vegans in this
population
and to carnivores in the general
population so while advertising to many
many people in a in a subgroup they are
still excluding it so in this particular
example the carnivores of a particular
population are the subgroup we want to
protect but of course nobody would
Define carnivores of
of any subgroup as as a protected group
so each
um task each algorithmic task brings
with it a variety of new groups that
need protections so what we are trying
to say is that
we shouldn't try to identify ahead of
time which groups need protections but
we should try to protect all the groups
that we can and simultaneously
so it sounds like a very ambitious goal
somehow you're saying that you are going
to have some abstract a notion of
protecting all groups a all subgroups uh
so uh can is there a mathematical
definition for it oh that's one question
and second of all can you achieve
right so
so certainly we cannot protect our verbs
and and here is where the theory
background comes into play
what we can do or can can try to do is
protect every group that we can identify
so if there is a group and the task of
looking at an individual Shafi and
saying isafi part of this group or not
if this is something that we can do
computationally then we hand every hope
of protecting this subgroup
and then so that our Notions come or the
notion of groups we want to protect come
from a computational abilities we're
trying to protect all the groups that we
can identify using our computational
resources it's still extremely ambitious
and but it turns out that that in many
many cases we can
and we can
deal with all the groups in very very
rich collections as long as some
learning capabilities are possible for
these groups and perhaps I shouldn't get
more technical than that but
um
as long as we can as these groups that
we want to protect are not too
complicated computationally then we can
protect them this certainly captures a
lot of the groups we care about so
groups like
intersection of some protected
attributes but also things that are more
sophisticated than that so in fact
multi-calibration has been implemented
and has been used in the real world and
there are various packages like our
package in
in other packages so it is doable and it
yeah I also I find it pretty surprising
that we can do so much of that
so you're using uh algorithms in two
ways one way is to using an algorithm to
identify whether I am a member of a
group or not because you were talking
about computational mobility and
secondly once that's been determined you
also have an algorithm for let's say
determining whether somebody should get
a job see a an ad for a job be accept it
to school a via another algorithm so
you're using algorithms here in two
possible in two different ways yeah at
least so essentially right there is this
uh
a principle in ethics that
art implies can
we cannot ask for to do something that's
impossible
and it cannot be a moral imperative to
do something that you cannot do
and in a sense we're being the
computational perspective and saying
what you can or cannot do depends on
your computational resources
as well as some
um
and information that you have but I
think the understanding that information
is important for fairness and the
quality of data is important for
fairness and was understood and what we
are trying to add is that the
computation
and the computational power is very very
important for fairness so what are the
resources of the people that design the
algorithms what are the resources of the
people that try to audit these
algorithms
and of course we haven't even discussed
the complexity of what would
discriminate what kind of discrimination
would mean and here we also perhaps want
to look at the computational power
of the algorithms that are trying to
discriminate
and we want to protect against
so you mentioned that you have packages
uh both a I assume at Stanford or in
other places uh and my question now is
what are some areas of application where
you've seen a multi-group
In fairness Notions and maybe encode or
maybe these packages applied
right so I think that the first place in
which
and this has been a
applied and then actually first in
experimental studies but then later
and in real life applications was the
medical Arena
and I think the medical arena is really
very primed to the specific so I've been
talking very generally about multi-group
fairness but for the specific notion
that we have to introduced his
multi-calibration
and that looks at kind of accuracy
sometimes as an aspect of fairness so
being inaccurate on a particular group
could be a sign of discrimination so in
the in the example we mentioned that you
predict the probability of a medical
condition
and if you're
inaccurate if you're predicting too high
a probability or too low probability in
both cases you're harming an individual
so what you really really want to be for
every individual is accurate and what
you
um
and want to make sure is that there is
no group that we are harming so actually
in very similar con cases they've shown
that them
the kind of predictors that are used day
to day when you go to the to the office
of your physician and the client is
algorithm for you or perhaps accurate in
general but very inaccurate on
subpopulations
and multi-group fairness
multi-calibration can be used to make
them much better on many many
sub-populations
and then kovit came and which gave an
example for an amazing application that
I wouldn't have imagined and this was
about two years since we introduced
multi-calibration
and that was used
um by Khalid Healthcare which is the
biggest healthcare provider in Israel
one of the biggest in the world
to create a predictor for covet
complications
the amazing thing was that at the time
they didn't have real data and they
didn't have real data from
um
from Israel they had some very
kind of course statistics from China
and they used our methods to get
something much better but perhaps in a
higher level
and whenever you want to deal
with the population that is very
heterogeneous
it were
um you cannot look at individuals all
the same but it's very important the
collection of attributes that they have
and then multi-grow fairness makes sense
so that was one Arena and there are
other Arenas like uh in general
statistics and perhaps we'll talk about
it a bit later
and so yeah we didn't create all of
these packages it's amazing uh miniature
rotation this didn't come from me but
this happened in many uh by many others
and so um
I I've been quite Amazed by how quickly
but you definitely know how the length
of time that it takes for Theory work to
get into practice and and here it was
much much quicker
so you mentioned the medical field uh
and uh in the medical field in in other
examples you've given you're always
talking about predictions
so you're trying to predict yes or no
um should get a medication shouldn't get
a medication is high risk for covert
isn't high risk for coping complications
should go on bail not unveil
um
I was uh it reminds me of an example
that I heard from someone else
self-driving cars and uh he was saying
suppose he was self-driving car and the
car is going to make a decision it
notices that uh women drivers are more
hesitant to cut so we may learn that
it's worth it if the driver and the
other car is a woman is to cut in front
of them because then you will probably
not be at risk of an accident
and uh it makes sense it's gonna get you
to work on an individual level earlier
but 10 years down the line for this
prediction there but 10 years down the
line uh all women are going to be coming
to work you know an hour later because
people have been cutting them so there's
also no this question of whether
something is fair or not
um
in a way that affects the future
who is still crucial prediction I guess
whether this person is likely to object
if you're going to cut in front of them
but uh the harm in that is is something
that only will determined later yeah
does that commit the research at all
absolutely I think that
you've kind of hinted on on several
different areas of research that
actually did come into play in in the
last Workshop I just say that your story
is not really perhaps it's uh it's still
a story for some driving cars but it's
not
a story for our society in general
and but because this is how
discrimination works right and and how
it propagates over time
and but with respect to algorithms and
there are several
questions here and in particular
so when you're doing predictions the
question is
how are you doing predictions that are
right at the moment
or you're trying to make decisions that
would have a positive impact in the
future
and this kind of Downstream effect plays
a huge importance in in many studies
and as one of the talks
in this Workshop talked about is kind of
and talked about a better future kind of
decisions for a better future
and so while we can still talk about
affirmative action and the Supreme Court
didn't uh rule against it
and
many of the things we do
like trying to understand
reality at the moment in the most
accurate way
could be used or should be viewed as a
step towards correcting and improving
and improving the and the world so
accuracy doesn't
mean necessarily that you're going to
use it
to propagate reality you can use it to
for affirmative action for social
engineering that's one thing another
thing is that beyond the predictions
there are interventions
so perhaps your decision is
not if to accept somebody to University
or not but rather when you accept them
to the university what kind of
um
intervention can be used to increase
their probability of success
and so interventions is a huge
area of study and causality and so many
of the things we've discussed like
multiple fairness as impacting causality
so not just
um
what's the prediction now but if I do a
particular action
what would happen then so what's the
treatment effect
and so absolutely right that we if we
just propagate reality it can become
worse and worse
yeah um I was thinking that when you
were talking about a lot of things for
example in cryptography it's taken 30
years or so to actually be used but I
think that you're right that covid-19
was sort of like a we were thrown into a
huge experiment and
um a multi-disciplinary experiment you
know doctors computer scientists
epidemiologists you know a
a government regulators and we had some
acts so there so put everything into a
much more rapid deployment
um imagine statistics so
um uh I hear more and more that
collecting statistics even via human
surveys getting someone to fill a survey
uh certainly even experimentation in the
field of medicine even animal uh animal
experiments in Labs uh Berkeley campus
and other campuses is uh it's
notoriously expensive and in fact if you
look at a lot of articles that come up
let's say in Science magazine very you
know respectable venues and you look at
the numbers that they're quoting they're
very small sometimes if you have an
experiment with 20
20 specimens uh certainly a something
like 100 is considered a huge
achievement in terms of the number of
samples that you have and they are on
the other hand when we talk about data
science and computer science we use we
use numbers you know when we talk about
large data we are talking about
hundreds and thousands you know to say
the least
so
um I understand that
that there might be some way that your
work on multi-group fairness in some
strange segue uh could help us maybe
reuse statistics or use uh statistics
that was used in one domain and another
one or perhaps
um
uh be happy with the fact that we have
smaller rather than larger samples
how is that
yeah so so that was a huge surprise for
me and and this was this example that I
will discuss but also other examples
were we cared about discrimination
and we definitely didn't try to find new
ways of doing things in machine learning
or new ways in statistics
but somehow there was there was
something here in this notion of
multiple fairness multi calibration that
seems to bring a kind of lots of impact
and new paradigms in in other domains
so specifically for the statistics case
yeah we've been hearing from our
collaborators in the statistic Arena
that
getting
data that is I mean there's some cheap
data like the ones that you can do by
setting up a survey on your web page
and but this kind of data is is also not
necessarily representative it's not the
distribution you want to and to
understand but rather the people that
visit your web page and are willing to
fill up these surveys
enter and other you know other data is
much much more expensive
and similarly if you run a medical
experiment and a medical study
in Stanford University you don't want to
have to do the same experiment
and same study in every other hospital
but if you use this in some other
hospital then you will have a different
distribution of individuals so this
question of how to translate
and signing statistical finding learning
findings
from one distribution to the other
is extremely motivated and highly
studied and in a very strange twist this
notion of multi calibration
seemed to give us something extremely
robust to this kind of distributional
shifts
and the intuition is that if you know
studying in Stanford we don't only care
about the general population
but we care about a lot of
sub-populations
then this study will be very very robust
to shifts because even if if in a
different hospital the mix of population
is different because what our findings
were good for each subpopulation they
will translate well
and so this gave us
this notion of universal adaptability
which says that without even knowing
where I want to transfer my findings I
can in one study
um
in one place translated to many many
other studies into other domains to
other places and and so that was one
case in which this notion that was about
discrimination translated to something
very powerful in a sense a new paradigm
in a different area of statistical
validity
so I realized that throughout the
questions I sometimes you use that you
use the notion multi-calibration and
sometimes multi-group fairness just for
the more uh stood listener can you uh
elaborate on the difference or
similarity of these two Notions right so
multi-group fairness is about
this idea that you want to provide
whatever notion of protection against
discrimination you want it not for a few
groups but you want it for a very rich
collection of verbs
multi-calibration which was the specific
notion that we introduced in
in my group was
um
is
is about what is the specific thing you
ask for each population and the specific
thing is this notion of calibration
which essentially means that what you
say and corresponds to reality so if you
say for for a particular individuals
that and one fourth of them will will
see a particular outcome one both of
them and will repay a loan then indeed
one-fourth of them will
so it just means that the the meaning of
what you say is the same in all
subpopulations that you consider
this one has been very uh useful it gave
us this notion of universal adaptability
it also gave us other Notions like
omniprediction and which again is kind
of trying to
to revisit a very very
[Music]
um
kind of common Paradigm in learning
which is lost minimization and gives us
a very very powerful way to
simultaneously minimize loss in many
many different ways
without necessarily even knowing ahead
of time what is the relevant loss we
care about
and it gave us this notion of outcoming
distinguishability that
and gives a new understanding of some
Notions and complexity Theory which is
completely
different or a sense gives us a new
understanding of what is the meaning of
individual probabilities
so yeah so multi calibration is a
particular form of multicore fairness
and which is uh
um and one of those that were used to
introduce this notion there were other
Notions introduced by a group of
scientists in um
in a university and simultaneously but
yeah multi calibration is this specific
one
so to rephrase what you said uh so
somewhat informally so multi-group
fairness requires uh some notion of
fairness that would hold across these
different groups Define in a way that
you would describe and multi-calibration
is a specific notion of fairness perhaps
yeah is that the whatever the
prediction that you make should actually
be to match what happens
um in reality yeah okay
um so the next question is really
because you cannot have any interview or
conversation or dinner
during May 2023 this is for the future
Generations we're going to watch this
polylog without mentioning
so that's all the Rave where this is
three or three point five or four I
think that one of the things that's
happened is that
even people who have been asleep and
have a notion notice that algorithms are
important and algorithmic fairness
um
is uh being discussed are now talking
about uh machine learning machine
learning algorithms in specifically I
think they're thinking about these
generative language models where you can
make these prompts and get these
incredibly intelligent sounding
responses and every day we get something
new so
um when you maybe elaborate on some
fairness related issues that are
particular to Chachi PT
absolutely I mean large languages models
all together I don't want to single out
open AI but it could be deep mind maybe
it could be Facebook could be
other groups coming up yeah
I think they they won't mind being
associated solely associated with this
notion of really talking about the
fairness issues so they might find that
so are there some things where fairness
related that we should pay attention to
especially today really May 2023 when a
lot of uh yeah people came out against
the release of open AI are calling for
pause or calling for regulation the
fairness play into this discussion yes
yes absolutely
um this entire area of ours and and of
course we come from a theory perspective
but we should say that it is a highly
multi-disciplinary area that is involves
philosophers and legal experts and
within CS it involves machine learning
and HCI and other Notions but I think
all of us in this growing
um
a community or communities of
researchers I think feel like this
and child that tries to to stop the
flood by sticking the hand in in the dam
before everything collapses why why stop
the flood you know not everybody shares
by the way and there are people on this
call
yeah yeah no I'm I'm may not share your
perspective no I'm not okay so that's
yeah okay so there is uh so the flow
that I want to stop is the flood of
discrimination
and
um
and I'm I'm not even asking about the
question of whether we should stop
[Music]
um
the progress because I think it's not a
question I don't think that it can be
stopped
so so the thing we are resting against
is huge developments and for us in our
area we're I mean our challenge is even
understanding
how to formalize how to understand how
to discuss all of these Notions
um
and chatipiti is is really an example
where there could be many additional
uh concerns so there could be concerns
of the form that already bothered us
before which is what is the quality of
the service quote unquote these language
models give different populations
and right when we looked at the language
understanding I remember when
um
no machine could understand my
my accent because I'm not I'm not
American
and then that has improved
similarly what the quality that we get
from jativity depends on which sources
of data they they are using this is one
source of discrimination the other
source of discrimination which is
perhaps more new is the fact that these
models are behaving like human beings
they are closer to and closer to
um
beating the Turing Challenge and
and now
um there's a question of how do they use
language
um so
discrimination of the form that we look
kind of at between individuals
and
um or what they're saying offensive in
this way or another is it more offensive
towards one population or another it is
it
[Music]
um
using stereotypes on one population
and then perhaps preserving these
stereotypes and so a lot of the
discussions that we didn't have before
when we were just worried about whether
we were going to get the loan or not
and now we I mean it's getting the loan
or not but what kind of information they
will let tell us in addition how would
they refuse us or not so I think that
GPT
I mean we are behind on other
technology in terms of formalizing
everything and giving new
and new models new Notions that if it is
completely open I think and I don't
think that the people that develop it
understand it well and understand the
concerns well and and I don't think the
community is understanding and we will
keep on
running behind this train
and trying to do the best that we can so
that's kind of the flawed method for the
flood is is not that
and I mean I think actually it is I mean
it's definitely a good question of do we
want to slow down or not but that's not
the question I I'm trying to answer in
my research in my research is trying to
say okay what can we say now what can we
do now with the with the technology
that's that's uh
and so fast
so in terms of is related to fairness it
seems to me uh people talk about maybe
that this is democratizing access to
technology
uh which sounds you know using at least
the word fairness in its colloquial
sense that
um there's something beautiful here is
that everybody has access to this
um so there's something fascinating
about the fact that this human
experiment is available to all what do
you think about that yeah for sure I
think that in general in technology
right there is a huge
and the potential
to combat a lot of discrimination so
many times when we look at technology
and we say it is discriminating in one
way or another
we are comparing it to an ideal that
never existed before
um and um so so I'm not there but I'm
also not in the in the camp that says
it's all good
so I think that it has good potential
and we cannot
um
ignore that but it also has the
potential of harm and uh and I guess
another thing that comes to mind in my
mind is a related to fairness and
charity is that it's providing a
laboratory for people like you and me uh
to kind of see uh that this system which
was designed in
according to principles that nobody
really truly comprehends their power uh
enables us to
um observe lack of fairness or uh and
run experiments I told I I uh that even
the way you phrase a question
if you ask please can you tell me some
information or
you demand to see some information you
will get different information
uh which is fascinating uh
I don't know what do you think about
that
and right and then that's the I mean
that's also the concern that uh if you
ask information in the way that GPT
understand better
or they will they will give it the
information that that you expect and if
you ask it in a different way perhaps
they will uh for example interpret you
as being aggressive
when you're not when this is just uh the
way you speak the way people like you
speak
um I think it's fascinating I think that
I think that there has been so I do take
your point that there has been also
demonization of Technology
and or idealization of humans in
parallel
and I don't feel that they are so
different or there are I think very very
few places in which
algorithms are more dangerous than
humans
and I can say one that I mean
that are more principal dangerous also
in the long term in the short term there
are lots of dangers but in the long term
I don't think that people are are better
in many inherent ways the only thing
that in which algorithms are so much
more dangerous is in scale
it could be that the same algorithm
and and some researchers in our
community are looking exactly at that
what happens when the same algorithm
makes decisions
in many many uh across an entire
industry so the same algorithm will
filter your CV for all the jobs or will
decide your loans in all the banks
so if before you went to a particular
Bank in a particular uh
racist potentially or sexist or any
other East
individual and discriminate against you
perhaps in a different bank you have a
better
option and that's one danger an
important to enter in algorithms that it
could be the same you're meeting the
same
algorithm again and again but yeah I
think that there is huge potentials also
for I mean
our society is not without faults so I
think algorithms here too have a huge
potential of of doing good but it
requires a lot of people in many
different communities to work on it can
you tell me maybe what were the big
surprises in the workshop uh I know you
are the organizers maybe they're not
surprises because you organized it but
still is there some highlights that you
can mention
or highlight I think for me the the huge
surprise
was how uh spread these Notions are it's
we're talking about research from about
five six years ago
and when I was starting to think with
other co-organizers about having this
workshop and I thought about it as first
is a way to kind of spread the word
and then perhaps to have better
understanding of of what a small
collections of individuals are already
doing
but going to the workshop and people
that kind of contacted us and said oh I
want to come and I do this I I have this
work that is related
I realized that these Notions that come
from fairness are already much more well
understood than I than I thought they
are and spread in communities that I
wasn't aware of
there and no knowing that so in
particular in machine learning and
statistics more people are working on it
and and using it
then then I realized so that's kind of
on the level of uh house spread so this
this for me was a surprise I will spread
this notion is
um the in addition the results were just
uh beautiful and there's tons of great
work done
and connections to complexity Theory are
very beautiful and some of them are new
to me
um
kind of all mathematical results that
are somehow improved Now using
techniques that come from a
completely different domain so like any
kind of good research it always has
applications beyond what it was intended
for
absolutely
um
let me ask you another question which I
didn't see work in the conference on and
occurs to me so you won't develop
methods or multi-calibration a multiple
fairness or other things that are
related to uh
essentially advising companies where
designing algorithms or inside or
advising individual entities who are
revising algorithms how to do it better
so we'll have better societal value and
societal impact how do you know that
they're doing how do you verify right
well that's a great question and of
course you're a much better person to
answer it and but um I don't know to
answer it but you can certainly ask it
yeah
um so
so yeah it's not only to design
algorithms but it also perhaps to audit
for algorithms
and to regulate algorithms and then when
we're talking about regulations then
verifying is important
again here
we do have the tension between companies
doing something that's proprietary they
don't want to give you the inside of
what they do
and um
and now can you prove it in some zero
knowledge way or some cryptographic
methods and I think that there is a lot
of research to do on that
you have been starting to work I mean in
this specific direction of fairness but
definitely for other emotions and
there was one working a great Wolfman
gave a talk about uh helping verify
properties of
distributions but
it seems to me that working furnace in
general has intersection with
essentially
any other area that they can think of
and we've seen intersections with Game
Theory methods that come from Game
Theory and that help get
multi-calibration intersection with
complexity theory in the section with
cryptography exactly around that and of
course machine learning and statistics
and so I think that what this Workshop
can do if if any is in course people
that have been hearing about this
furnace thing for a while and uh okay
perhaps we are too late
and say no there are foundational
aspects
of avoiding furnace that are we just
starting to understand
and whatever area you come from it's
very very likely that what you're
bringing to the table could could be
useful my analogy and you can tell me
much better I mean when I studied
cryptography and I worked in
cryptography I would say oh if I was
active just
earlier like in the 80s
I could have done these amazing
fundamental work foundational work and
my feeling is that algorithm fairness
is a little bit like cryptography in the
80s
that's my analogy
no absolutely
um this issue that I asked about
verifying uh it's not just because it's
my own
night before this these methods for
verification where verifying is separate
from the act of doing so say you are
someone who designed an algorithm you
think maybe you've done your best maybe
you you were trying to pretend you've
done your best this issue of
verification I think is very important
in the field where it's going to we're
going to assume that this is deployed
and then we might relax and I don't
think we should relax because
um you know there might be incentives
not to be fair because it might be
cheaper for you it might require less
effort maybe you want to discriminate
um and I think the question of verifying
is is key
um I think you agree with me in any case
in general I think that there should be
very little relaxing in this area
because we understood very early on is
that there is no not going to be one
notion of fairness
and this means that everything you do
towards one and a notion of fairness May
harm you in a different aspect
so you should always be debating what is
the Discrimination you want to protect
against
and then uh if you describe ask are you
protecting against and this is where
verification cryptography could play a
huge a huge role
so this is almost the last question so I
know there's been a long interview a I
think in 2018 there was a cluster In
algorithmic fairness assignments
Institute were there there was also a
workshop at the time uh that had a lot
of Scholars from other fields not just
the computer scientists not just
theoretical people scientists people
from law from public policy and they at
that time showed a great uh
concern uh as to who are we as
algorithms people uh uh in the sense how
do we know that we are going to uh make
a positive impact rather than sort of
shake everything up the officers replace
laws
um so I recall that I I think that the
field and the attitudes of the field has
changed quite a bit and um I was
wondering what you think about it and
whether
um there's any legal Frameworks that
have been developed since about actually
applying
um you know algorithms statistical
predictive models for individuals
yeah and there's lots in what you ask
and one they said first these these
clusters were very important because
I mean
individuals try to look at the
particular area and say oh you know it's
important I want to do something good in
it but we know that progress is done by
a community real progress it's very hard
in our field
to make a big focus in areas that are
new like algorithmic fairness just by
yourself
and so the two summers that we had at
the Simon Institute were kind of like
these small Laboratories of can we work
together what do we care about what do
other communities uh care about and they
were very instrumental and I think it
also encourages to do this uh
um Simon's collaboration so another arm
of the Simons foundation and that we're
part of this seventh collaboration on
the foundation of algorithm fairness
which again beyond all the beautiful
results it's a lot about Community
Building
and I have the feeling that with these
two efforts and others we're getting
closer and closer to a very very Vibrant
Community that can really do major
changes
typically you were talking about this uh
wrong at the route
the name of the workshop was wrong at
the root right yeah and which was
really an amazing Workshop it wrote uh
[Music]
um
people from really a very different
communities
philosophy sociology law
and it was
um not an easy Workshop to be part of
right
a different communities have really
Beyond different language different
values
so for example we encountered uh
people that from their perspective very
justifiably they have YouTube mistrust
in science in
in math and definitely in algorithms
and it was a very important discussion
to start having
um and I don't think we are resolving
every everything or perhaps it resolved
anything
and because I feel that all of these
communities have a role to play
but I think that it helped the different
communities do their job better in
particular the
Theory community
and enters this with a bit of a better
understanding of what brothers other
communities so I think this was
really very provocative and eye-opening
and important event
but in terms of legal uh Frameworks are
they emerging uh yeah so the legal World
um is much more conservative
and then computer science and Theory
and so things we understand and it's not
only In fairness in privacy for example
um some of the regulations and laws that
are in privacy
are highly highly outdated
um and I think it's going to be still a
huge effort this effort happening more
and more
so there are more and more discussions
between
and essentially between scientists in
different areas with and and Joint
courses that you were part of one and so
there's a lot of discussion and I think
there's there are Beginnings but there's
still huge differences so the first
paper that we mentioned a few times we
called it furnace through awareness
and one of the insights was that you
should be aware
of
um
cultural differences you should be aware
of the
um the sensitive attributes to provide
fairness
and this is still something that's very
controversial in the legal Arena many
times you're not even allowed to see a
sensitive attribute
and so there are huge differences both
in
what we find and for example this
question of access to sensitive
attributes there's huge difference in
values and there are huge differences in
in the character
like how quickly the area
progresses so if the Artisans are
chasing the
the high-tech progress I think the legal
experts are still chasing even us and so
but but it's a huge area now with lots
of great people working on it so I'm I
am optimistic of the progress and I
think that there are good reasons why
and the legal World should be a little
bit more conservative
so instead of chasing I would have used
the word lagging behind uh so if we
crawl behind practice you know they're
crawling
behind us uh you know you're I
completely agree with you that
um
you know that example that you gave
about
not being aware is a required legal
requirement versus
saying that we actually need all these
attributes in order to do algorithms
properly is a great example it reminds
me of another example many years ago I
guess at this point maybe it was 2000 uh
18 there was a workshop that Cynthia
dork ran at Harvard and about fairness
but it was really not talking about
definitions just bringing people more
walks of the University uh to talk about
it and um
it was brought up that suppose the two
candidates for acceptance the school
they have exactly the same the same
record how do you are deciding but you
have only one slot how do you decide
between them and one of the computer
scientists said oh you toss a coin and
if it's heads you let the somebody one
person tells the other and uh several of
the social scientists were kind of
outrage said that's not fair they use
the word
fairs whereas as mathematicians there
isn't anything more fair than that
because we don't control it but it just
sort of highlighted how differently we
think about yeah and this is yeah the
question of
after the fact and and before kind of
fairness
there are other
um
points uh words
that I think are kind of more about
values that I think are important one is
that
[Music]
um
there is this question of how defined
you want to be to have things
and in a sense obfuscation is is almost
a value in the legal system
and we've seen it in
for example in the Supreme Court
decisions on all decisions about
affirmative action
the thing that passed the Supreme Court
were the more obfuscated affirmative
action rather than the transparent one
um
it could be subject to interpretation
you're saying because
right
and in addition there is a view of
um
so here is I think I think everything
that we said before I think I completely
understand I think one place where I
think
perhaps some of the legal experts are
not having it completely right is that
their views of differences between
humans and algorithms
my eyes are
um
not as strong as they as they would
would put them
where they view algorithms making
decisions based on the past
based on patterns
and and would not put humans in the same
category and in the law right you're not
supposed to
[Music]
um
punish people from for people for
something that they may do
or and so on and I do believe that this
is all very
serious concern at the moment
but I don't think that it's such
a true
separation between algorithms and humans
I think that often humans are
the product of all their past
experiences and the patterns that
they've been observing
and they are making decisions based on
the past rather than
and so I think that there is a lot more
for us as communities to discuss and to
understand
it's a huge challenge because we want
our
um
our things to be relevant in the real
world and and so I think that we as a
community person instead of looking at
the lagging behind I think we are
between two
different communities that are pulling
us in different directions between them
I think industry and some of the machine
learning researchers that say we can do
all these amazing things let machine
learning be machine learning and that's
the best outcome that's possible
and between other communities works on
the legal Arena and others it
tells us
I mean
stop completely and and this is all
wrong
and algorithms are
discriminatory by definition compared to
humans in a sense perhaps I'm
exaggerating but I do feel that our
communities are kind of between this and
I hope that we are striking a better
balance than both
yeah and I would say as theorists are
yet another Community where we are
willing to uh with the we sort of demand
that things will be well defined and
that we can prove them and at the same
time once they are well defined and we
can prove them we think that's good
enough so there's plus and minuses of
that a fascinating discussion and I I
you know I have a lot of other questions
I want to ask you but I think that I
should let you go and I want to really
be express my gratitude for you this
interview for organizing the workshop
and for all the work you've done on
algorithmic fairness and then you will
do on an algorithmic awareness and many
other things thank you woman thank you
so much